let's imagine a reaction where we start
with the reactants A and B and they
react to form the products C and D now
it turns out that in certain situations
the reaction could go the other way you
could start with C+ D and those could
react to end up with a plus b so when
you have a reaction like this that could
go in either direction we call that a
reversible reaction and that's why the
title of this video reversible reactions
and equilibrium and one way to say that
it could go in either direction is to
write it like this A+ B and we use these
half arrows so it could go in that
direction or it could go in this
direction you could go to C plus d and
what's going to happen is the reaction
is going to go in both directions so a
plus b is going to react to form C plus
d and c plus d is going to react to form
a plus b and at some point you're going
to be hitting an equilibrium that's the
point at which the forward reaction is
happening at the same rate as I guess
you could consider it to be the backward
reaction going from C plus d to a plus b
now once you're at equilibrium it
doesn't mean that the reactions stop it
just means that the rate of going from a
plus B to C plus d is the same as the as
the rate of going from C plus d to a
plus b this is a really important thing
to realize a common misconception is
that people think at equilibrium somehow
the these reactions stop that is not the
case it's just that the rate of the
forward reaction and the backward
reaction has now become the same rate so
even though you continue to have a plus
b forming C plus d
you have the same rate at which C plus d
is now also going and forming A+ B
another misconception here is is that
the concentrations of a b and c and d
once you're in equilibrium they would
have stabilized but it's not necessarily
that the concentrations are equal the
point at which we're in equilibrium you
might have a much lower concentration of
c and d than a or b or the other way
around what equilibrium is telling us is
that at equilibrium the forward rate of
reaction is equal to the backward rate
of
reaction